kendall jenner and devin booker have
broken up but is it really over well a
source tells e.t it may not be it's not
always easy kendall and devon are going
their separate ways after two years
together our source says kendall feels
like they're on different paths and they
have had discussions about their future
but they are not on the same page
however there is a possibility they
could get back together in the future
what's happening with you and devin
booker
um he's my boyfriend
that's kenny during the keeping up with
the kardashians reunion special last
year finally admitting she was dating
devin the two kept their relationship
relatively private since first being
romantically linked in june 2020. kylie
and i specifically have you know had the
opportunity to watch my older sisters
you know go through marriages and
and relationships and breakups and all
these things and and do them i have to
be there for you no do them pretty
publicly and like again no offense to
you guys at all but i think just it was
personal preference
from like a really young age and since
then kendall and devon were more open
about each other on social media sharing
cute pics like these
the model was also no stranger to
sitting courtside and supporting her man
at his basketball games
remember this rare moment of pda at his
game in los angeles i watch every game
unless i have last night i had a dinner
but all my friends and family know that
i like sit with my phone wherever i am
and back in january of this year things
started getting serious between them a
source told et at the time the couple
were in a really great space and that
they've really fallen hard for one
another then in march devon opened up to
wsj magazine about being with kendall
and talked about whether it was hard to
have the spotlight on his personal and
professional life i wouldn't say hard
honestly i'm enjoying life to the
fullest and that came off my tongue so
easily because it wasn't always this way
but i feel like i'm in a good place
right now and plus our source said at
the time devon had kendall's fam's stamp
of approval
i mean it's so exciting kendall's family
loves devon and think he is super
talented they think he's just the type
of guy that kendall needs he is athletic
sweet fun and still a gentleman
so if there's a chance the two may get
back together the family may still be
team devin
[Music]